白い画面よく使うんですけど
あれがちょっと明るすぎて見にくいっていうコメントもいいんですけど
消したらこんなもんです比べないですかくらいですよねため太陽めちが悪いからこう
なるんですけどそう
彼はが暗くなるんでー
あんまりちょっと
よくないなぁと思ってと設定
ほどよい明るさにできないんで
これか暗すぎるが明るすぎるだったら束から声優のほうがいい
僕のイメージアップに
僕っていうか動画のイメージアップになると思うんで
明るくします
ええっ
バイトなう
厳しいんですよ今一番ちょっと頑張らなきゃいけないところなんですよ
なんでちょっと
軽く済ませます西発売の
家犯罪期間限定のプレミアうろりてぃカーファンのハーフです
後輩ってええ
レアチーズクリーム苺クリームイチゴスポンジ
プレースポンチっていうね
なんか
まさにニューハーフみたいな感じですアベニール
は0
ちょっと割合的に
ちょっと割合的に一坊が少なめになってますね
まあそうですよこの中のこの世の中の全てが均等というわけではありませんからねそう
有効なんで社会的な
ねっ
道徳的なアレもを急いで切れる
喜劇になってるんですよ
いただきます
うまいレアチーズの方の酸味がすごい効いてますこれなんかに誕生日ケーキの味がする
んですよ
量も少ないように見えて結構1個食べたら鼻に来れねえ
阿部を三重に来るもんじゃないしてねーな
もう朝土産舌よ
はっはっは
雑考あるんですよ僕
もう
ee
動く弁当ん
うふーたん wh
1どっ
スーパー
おっ
危うくん
うそふーん
こんなんアーサーっっ
ee ああああ
ええええええ
a 3
me